did you follow the rnc of the DNC back
in 2016 of course there was there was
like no protest at the RNC nobody cared
yeah and Trump was was the one getting
nominated you know was mind blowing me I
was at both I was covering this for a
progressive media outlet fusion it was
so woke at the RNC in almost no protest
and I'm watching at a bar across the
street because we were there to cover
the peripheral not the inside and
Trump's giving the speech and he talks
about our LGBTQ community and every
thoughts clapping and cheering that was
the Republican convention at the
Democratic convention there were
thousands of people trying to storm the
barricades and in mass protest and
police grabbing people and arresting
them that was the Democratic Party the
craziest thing to me and it's a really
good example of something happened
there's this group called juice News I
don't know if you've ever heard of them
they're a YouTube channel and they did a
show called rap news one of the clips
they made was about WikiLeaks how the
world approves of what Julian Assange
does in spreading the truth how Hillary
Clinton was a war monger how Alex Jones
was warming up the coming fascists and
about how the government was trying to
turn back the clock on freedom of speech
this was a long good left-wing segment
this was leftist activist media today
sounds like a trump supporter doesn't it
yeah that's why it's so weird yeah and
so whatever that shift was was
exemplified to me at the RNC DNC when it
was the the people I knew on the Left
protesting the Democrats not the
Republicans they didn't show I was
shocked I thought it was gonna be like
you know RNC was like 2007 or 2008 or
whatever when you know people that those
people in the van had like weapons and
got arrested because you know they were
protesting the Republicans know it was
Democrats I think it's gonna be similar
this time and I think maybe they'll ride
after Trump wins again but here's one
here's my prediction probably gonna be
wrong that's fine
you know I say that because I think this
is likely I think a lot of people are
going to be you know candidate or bust
yang or bust Biden or bust Bert moody
ginger bust Bernie or bust and their
second choice is gonna be Trump I think
it's gonna so it was nine point four
million people who went from Obama to
Trump
I think it's gonna be massive this could
be I could be in a bubble I could be
wrong I think I'm right everybody thinks
they do but I think Trump is gonna win
more than people realize and it's going
to send a shock to the system for the
Democrats we saw what happened in the UK
right you see on the 13th you see what
happened I mean tell me what happened to
the biggest defeat of the left oh it's
like a hundred years yeah yeah yeah they
were able a burr setback major setback
and I'm trying to explain to my friends
this and I said imagine if a portion of
Los Angeles voted Republican like like
I'm talking like LA and they were like
that'll never happen it's impossible I'm
like there were parts of you know there
were cities that we had voted liberal
like labor left since 1929 flipped for
the Conservatives and we followed in
their footsteps with brexit brexit came
first the populist wave then Trump got
elected were on the same track a lot of
people say things I'm not gonna happen
I'm not gonna plan to be a prophet but I
there are some people that have been
than predicting a Trump slide in 2020 as
far back as 2016 and I think that I'm
probably in that camp because I really
believe that these forces are are
fundamental issues these are not surface
level issues these are deep down these
are like versions competing versions of
reality competing versions of what
science is what truth is what sex is
what gender is what men are what women
are what relationships should be like
these things these are at the core of
this separation and it's even becoming
less and less about economics and
healthcare it's it's about these
fundamental issues about who we are as
human beings and these things aren't
going to change and these these these
divisions are just gonna grow and I'm
fairly certain I'm very confident I
think that Trump is gonna win
irrespective of whichever candidate
right now comes up from the Democrats
yeah I agree and I but I think it's
gonna be a hot summer though I think
that there's gonna be a lot of action
there's gonna be a lot of quality things
to attend events to see and I hope it
doesn't get too bad but interestingly
you address it that who's gonna be the
most upset
who would overreact the most let's say
Bernie wins will burn Bernie wins all
2020 will Trump supporters like rage in
Washington DC setting cars on fire
smashing glass I'm never gonna happen
probably not gonna happen is it never
know it would never happen it's never
gonna happen like for example I went to
the Richmond gun rally on January 20th
and there was about 20,000 people there
and I wanted to go I support the Second
Amendment myself I just wanted to go
check it out cover it take some pictures
and see it see it from up with my own
eyes it was the nicest group of people
you ever been totally right I would make
a bet if Donald Trump wins I would bet
that the left would riot yes if Bernie
Sanders wins I would bet that the left
would riot
there's no circumstance where out look
because I've been to these events do you
know what I've seen throughout my career
going on the ground of protests with
conservatives they sit in little chairs
and wave little American flags that's
that's that's like been the gist of it
now of course there have been you know
skirmishes with on the ground protests
between certain groups right but when it
comes to the majority of Trump
supporters they're not gonna go outside
they're not gonna go in March and smash
windows they've never done that I mean
they're law and order people also for
one right which is funny you know the
the Donald subreddit yeah that
quarantine because they were threatening
cops apparently yeah it's completely
absurd like the lot the blue lives
matter people are you nuts I don't know
reddit is just some universe that exists
that I have no idea what's going on but
let me never been there let me go back
to what you're saying about the gender
stuff in any stuff yeah what I'm seeing
now on the left in terms of mainstream
talking points is like they've they've
run they've they've gone off the track
right we have a left and a right
train train track with both cards you
know slowly moving a little left low
right something happened and the cart
for the left bumped off and you started
going straight left and now you have you
know aoc saying if we don't get our act
together in twelve years you know this
could be the end of the world she was
being hyperbolic I get that I want to be
fair she wasn't literally saying the
world can end but Greta Thun Berg said
we have eight years the number keeps
changing it's getting more dramatic and
even if it wasn't their intention people
on the Democrat side picked up that
rhetoric like we have ten years left
before the world
seriously becomes you know irreversibly
damaged we can't save it and I'm like
I've always been concerned by the
environment I worked for Greenpeace and
none of us would say that kind of crazy
nonsense we would talk about the urgency
of core issues
like hey there was an act that there was
an oil spill at Deepwater Horizon can we
get some support to like you know fight
for certain regulations to make sure
this stuff doesn't happen we weren't
going around screaming the end is nigh
and now you now you have that so that's
all about motivating people and getting
people scared and giving them like a
bigger larger thing to fear that's even
bigger than people sitting across the
aisle this is it's cataclysmic it's in
ya world stuff it's like biblical end of
days kind of thing and like they're
using it in the same way that you know
people miss having the Soviet Union
right the Soviet Union was way to keep
people focused and rally us against the
common enemy yeah and climate change or
not climate change per se but climate
Cataclysm right and yeah the world
climate stuff that's that's all about
political motivation brainwashing
building cult you know putting people
against something that's bigger than
them and just making them scared it's
about scaring people into submission and
then they use little girls to spread the
word how difficult was it for me to ask
you to cook like for you to decide to
come on this podcast with me well you
know I had to check your subscriber
count and stuff first and then I decide
it was about how many seconds it take
for you to be like oh yeah I can
definitely come out right away
do you know hard it is to do the app to
do this with people who are on the
political left I can imagine is very
difficult on with a few people over
Skype and stuff there's a few people I
absolutely respect who have come on and
had conversations with me I've had a
conversation with Sam cedar David Pakman
much respect for their willingness to
have that conversation even though we
definitely disagree but man I always
when it comes to big stories know that I
have to reach out to people on the Left
first because it takes forever yeah and
they typically say no yeah I it's it and
and this is what leads me to think that
Jerry Tim you're scary because you're
you're on your unrestrained you're you
you can do you be um say exactly what
you want that's terrifying
you don't come with a style guide they
don't know exactly what you're gonna say
how you're gonna ask it they're on edge
they're afraid of being exposed well
it's because there is a cult and it's
and it's not that everyone on the left
is in it but they're all scared of it
yeah so I was watching Bill Maher I
think it was two weeks ago and he was
talking about Elizabeth Warren and how
she said she would have a trans teenager
that her you know Department of a
Secretary of Education or whatever and
he said forget the trans thing it's
insane that she would have a high
schooler pick someone in her cabinet he
turns to the democratic congresswoman
and he says you would say something
right and boy did she not want to she
was she pumped on that it did she did
she say how stupid it was
no she punted yeah she kind of
sidestepped and kind of like didn't
dress late you know what I'd say if Bill
Maher said you wouldn't I'd be like
absolutely that's nuts you know look man
first of all you're right about the
trance thing why would Bosworth Warren
give a kid the right to you know
supersede her decision on a cabinet
member but what does it have to do with
anything anyway but this Democratic
woman was I could see it in her face and
maybe just my assumptions but I was like
oh she was worried she was worried
they'll come for her when some classes
at war in a Republican at one point Oh
totally yeah well she was a Republican
Native American so who is driving all
this I think I think what it is and it
ties in with what happens when you go to
college you go to college you get
brainwashed get on social media get
brainwashed even more and then you're 28
years old and then you're working for a
campaign and then you think you know the
whole world and you're telling these
candidates these are the issues that you
have to take up right and maybe they're
doing Twitter polls a sweater is because
because I don't know how your Facebook
like Bernie Sanders is not keeping up
with this kind of social commentary in
the dialogue and whatever you know so
somebody is telling him they're all
getting this horrible advice because I
don't think any of them believe anything
if they say anyway right I'd agree right
so so think Trump does right well except
for him that's why we love him right
here we see we we see we almost almost
so who's tell us who's telling Elizabeth
Warren that she needs to advocate her
authority to a trans teenager who really
by all measures if is she's a trans
teenager my personal belief is that
person should be doing nothing but
attending to their personal and mental
health not being faced with having to
make a decision that's gonna affect the
entire country choosing a white house
cat that's that's abuse it's like abuse
of that little kid it's it's it's it's
meaningless right which means wire why I
don't know you know I have some ideas I
worked for a company called
it was owned by ABC and Univision they
poached me from vice you know I went and
joined them and when they when they
first started they said we're gonna be
these posters on the wall we're
non-partisan you know and that was like
one of their big things something
happened about seven months after I
joined where they just said you know
what we've changed their mind we're woke
now and I talked to some people and I'm
gonna be very vague here to respect some
privacy but some people involved in the
company in certain capacity said the
marketing people and the consultants
told us two important facts women are
more likely to share content angry
people are more likely to share content
if we if we create our content for angry
women we will get more traffic and make
more money that's all true yes
to a certain extent their conclusion was
false but it is true that women share
more yeah it is true that anger it's the
most shares but creating a company
around the identity of being an angry
woman did not work and the company just
completely flushed itself out of
existence they had a very popular show
called
I think it was called drug wars where
they embedded with like federales in
Mexico and US Special Forces to watch
like it was it was edgy stuff they were
breaking into like cartel buildings and
like going after dealers and you watch
the arrests and then all of a sudden
they had this very popular you know
brand they had these shows that were
travel they got woke and totally went
broke and it was the marketing people
who are looking at social media data so
here's what I think happens Twitter
represents 2.2 percent of America so 80
percent of the tweets on Twitter the
active users 2.2 percent of this country
of that 1.2 percent is is the woke
Twitter audience yet the media here's
what's happening I worked in these media
companies when you go to a job they want
to know how many followers you have you
know why you got you got 50,000
followers you're gonna get a lot of
viewers look although there's almost
7,000 people watching huh we want to
hire this person so when they read an
article people will watch Twitter is is
woke insane far-left activists and so
what happens is the people who have
these these follower counts
have to cater to that to build those
audiences their narcissistic their
sociopathic they want to be out in front
and center everyone can see them oh I
want more followers and more followers
they get hired by these media companies
write more stories and it's basically a
toilet it is it is the water is swirling
around and they're all chasing after
each other as they sink to the bottom
and eventually get flushed out yeah so
another way of saying all that is its
money driven right absolutely yeah it's
all about money and but yeah it's
actually about unproven montt you know
theories about how to make money because
haven't we seen a number of lefty
publications go by the wayside over the
last couple of years who've completely
lost the plot because they spend all
their time focusing on this stuff when I
mean it's not what the thing is is what
is making money people are having
trouble figuring out what is making
money the old-line media I think is
having trouble with totally new guys we
figured it out we're figuring out how to
do it and it's figuring out and it's
it's compelling us towards our own
truths which is the best part about my
job is best part about your job I
imagine I'm on an intellectual journey
where I get to interview people and they
have them on my podcast and write books
and travel around the country talking to
people and it's it's being supported by
the people that want me to continue on
the same journey speaking of which what
is your what's your podcast oh well
podcast is Jack Murphy live you can find
that on iTunes and Spotify everywhere
else all around we got season two
kicking off first I was coming up was
gonna be Scott Adams coming up next week
awesome
yeah so it's a good one to get started
with and you know I also run a private
community called the liminal order and
that's a liminal - order calm and that's
an all men's community and we're all
sort of focused around the same sort of
set of values which is you know we we
have none want nothing to do with the
left and we believe in individual
accountability and we believe in taking
care of ourselves first then our family
and then our community and maybe then
the nation very Liberty minded I'd
imagine very Liberty minded
individualist but yet you know focused
on family and community and it's you
know we study things that are helping us
understand this world better today and
we're also working on things to help us
become better people
meditation physical fitness
communication strategies you know
cognitive behavioral therapy lots of
stuff yeah we're doing courses we've got
PhD professors in they're teaching
courses
we've got guys from the Naval Academy
teaching you know military strategy
stuff so you can better understand the
world but my point here and we can talk
about that as much as like I'd love to
well yeah yeah is that you know they are
helping me and we're all along on this
journey together where we're we're going
down our own path for truth and we're
all working together to try to find the
answers that are finding the answers and
to find a way to live within this world
that is just full conflict and hate and
racism and trying to find a way that we
can be our best selves in this
environment and so that's our pursuit of
truth and knowledge and information and
it creates media off of that and it's
funded by the people that are
participating and it's guiding it and so
that that works that's a model that
works for me your models working for you
too I just talked about my feelings on
the Internet
right you you know you've monetize your
feelings yeah that's amazing it's
actually kind of a modern miracle when
you think yeah and I've done much the
same to like I tweet a lot about family
issues and fatherhood and masculinity
and such and I tweet about my son quite
a bit and those tweets do super good
super well they go viral you know a
million impressions and then people
filter through they find the book they
buy the book they listen to the podcast
they joined the community and so it's
very odd actually phenomenon that I'm
able to just talk about myself and my
insights from my own life and it turned
it's turned into a career but so I'll go
back to what you're talking about the
the media kind of dying out these these
sites I think they're going through what
I would call like the blockbuster
phenomenon like Blockbuster Video here's
the way I see it these companies built
up this business model throughout the
the to thousands of 2010's where there
was a certain point where they realized
that to get the maximum Facebook
algorithm you needed to create shock
content like I mentioned for women so
what started becoming prominent we've
seen this data through LexisNexis where
words like critical race Theory racism
bigotry intersectionality just
skyrocketed like crazy because these
articles that combined all of these
different ideas were more likely to get
shared they built this business model
they made millions of dollars off of
monetizing rage in young people creating
this class of weird cultist types but
now that people are sort of breaking
away in there over
and week this can bring us into another
segment talking about dating but what's
happening is those business models are
decaying these these woke leftist
companies are laying people off like
crazy they're monitor their their their
businesses are just not putting the
money on anymore
meanwhile conservative many media is
skyrocketing and independent podcast in
media like mine or more importantly like
Joe Rogan being the biggest podcast he's
certainly not woke these are the things
that are dominating because he
definitely not woken up apparently over
the last couple of weeks right oh
they've been going after him like it's
it's nuts but here's the thing these
these Vox BuzzFeed they're inauthentic
they're plastic people with plastic
opinions to try and manipulate the
algorithm they accuse us of being that
way but when people listen they're like
this is two dudes having a conversation
like nobody wrote a script we're not
making things up was we as we have a
conversation right but when you watch
Vox well they did write a script they
plan that out they mapped out their
buzzwords and their keywords to maximize
that algorithm guess what's not working
anymore people are tired of the image
right I think people can totally feel
that yeah it's all performative yep and
you and I were talking earlier you you
think that this is coming to a climax
soon maybe that this woke this this woke
phenomenon is gonna work itself out and
then we're gonna have like an awakening
do you Adi woken Inge well maybe a civil
war because if Trump wins we go what
we're going there now oh yeah yeah yeah
well so so yeah let's let's uh let's
let's call it that there there was a guy
the other day drove his van through a
Republican voter tent I wonder why that
didn't make every headline every media
there was oh we know about what happened
in Charles Ville no one like no one in
their right mind was happy about that
only the crazy people were happy about
what happened at that event but there
was a there's every so often there's
some leftist protesters will get in the
street and they'll block it and then
someone will idle their car slowly
moving through them and what what do I
hear from from the BuzzFeed's from the
boxes this is just like Charlotte's
ville all over again
and I'm like dude okay it's not smart to
do what that guy did they put their car
in idle so it's going a mile an hour
slowly pushing towards people as they
back
I gotta go to work right and I and I
think look man if people are protesting
you've got to err on the side of safety
and don't try and you know even inch
your car through this is my opinion I
don't think he was plowing through
anybody but now we have a story about a
dude who actually rammed his car into
that voter tent and it's like nobody
talked about it
the Conservatives did the Trump
supporters did and so it's probably
where you fought white why you find me
on in the area I am where I'm talking
about it because it's nuts yeah well it
goes back exactly to the same thing I
was talking about the the Richmond rally
so when I was there everybody was super
cool super chill they were African
Americans there with their guns people
are taking pictures but then the news
reports man the news report I just like
this is the worst thing ever these
people are all violent militia military
men storm trooper in through this video
what would they do if there were black
people there they would wouldn't let
that happen can't have black people have
guns and the Panthers were there right
they were there yep so it's a the media
decides what we're going to be upset by
and what we're gonna talk about so what
happens when you have millions of people
who are an indoctrinated by rage bait
media Donald Trump wins with a bigger
majority than he did in 2016 making them
feel like it's gonna be bigger yeah
they're gonna feel that they're
definitely gonna feel that because he's
I think he's going to Anu only won by 77
thousand votes across three states right
in the electoral college before and I
have a feeling that those statesmen
Michigan Pennsylvania Ohio are gonna go
even more and he brought back the Ford
deal the Ford plant 3,000 jobs on like a
billion dollars yeah he's gonna he's
gonna do a lot better yeah I could be
wrong but what happens then when you
have these people who for a decade have
been indoctrinated about the rising
fascists you see these videos where
there were some Republicans at a college
I don't have you saw the viral clip and
the dude stops and starts screaming
about slitting Republican throats and
how they all have to die and all this
crazy stuff there's a lot of these
people and what happens when even like
them and their friends who are
completely indoctrinated see regular
Americans becoming fascist and what do
think they're gonna do well I think it's
interesting to think about what would
the form of a conflict look like you
know like standard you know blue and
gray on the other side of the field with
muskets that's not gonna happen ever
right but there's a new way of kind of
conducting war and it's already
happening
you know media manipulation and cancel
culture take you know political and
social assassination exile take capsule
culture take away your ability to
conduct financial transactions keep you
know take away your ability to earn an
income you know just completely slammer
you that mean it's happened to me I've
seen it happen bunch of people and
there's just more ways to conduct a
conflict these days then then
traditional even back to World War two
or never it's just it's just gonna be a
different kind of conflict actually
already ongoing and we're in at very
moment yeah we're in it and I think one
of the most important things is when you
see these stories about like running
through the the reg voter Eric voter
tent I don't think matters that much
obviously it matters to the people the
guy attacked it matters in the sense
that this guy text somebody totally
respect that but I'm talking about in
terms of civil war is the fact that
there were a bunch of there's there's a
bunch of people in the executive
administer in the executive branch that
were actively plotting against the
president that work that one guy wrote a
book about it they're an anonymous
warning we're doing everything to stop
that whoa whoa whoa right and then when
Obama fires these people they claim it's
the heads on a pike period that the end
is here he's coming for the families now
and they exaggerate everything so I
think the media is gonna drive something
truly terrifying and and these people
they don't understand because it's not
the snowflake doesn't blame itself for
the Avalanche but when they write
stories claiming this is the Friday
night Massacre because Trump fired some
dude they've lost it but people they see
this at home and they're panicking they
get in their van and they plow through a
Republican tent freaking out like it's
happening or they show up at a college
and they scream oh you're all fascists
and they go with clubs and they beat
people that's what I'm worried about
if these people are pushed to snap
there's antifa
and Tifa and the extremists are they are
they really and maybe I'm gonna catch
some crap for this but are they really
like representative of the Democratic
Party are they really no it's not but
they're just like this crazy group of
people that are sort of working on the
same issue
so there's got to be some sort of
accountability from the left they have
to right this is that they have to do
something themselves but this what I
mean is worrying me when and if it does
the stuff we see apology pieces
we see the media saying like auntie foe
the true heroes mm-hmm when they're
doing crazy things and then you know a
good example of like what worried me was
when I was in Boston at this condos that
there was a conflict there was a right
wing side and left wing side I got a
funny little side note for Hilton a
second but auntie foe was standing all
in front of the left-wing protesters
holding clubs and bats and crowbars and
they were wearing masks across the way
the right side were holding shields and
I was I was doing an interview with a
guy from the TSA and I point that out I
said well does that make you feel like
if you look at the right-wingers none of
whom are armed they're actually holding
shields your guys have weapons and he
said auntie fuzz not with us and I said
will you tell him to leave they said no
they're here in solidarity so they are
with you well no we didn't tell him to
come are you gonna stand up to them and
tell them and take their weapons and
leave or no and he said no and I said he
start pointing out how but the other
side youth understand how dangerous they
are and these people want to protect
minorities and he pointed to a
confederate flag and I said that's one
guy with a confederate flag over the
other side and he's not even like part
of the main group and he was like it
doesn't matter they're allowing him to
be there and I turned around and it was
a Soviet flag on their side and I said
and what about your Soviet flag and he
said we don't have one and I pointed and
he went oh geez I didn't know about that
yeah but up so LARPing LARPing is like
an epidemic right now I mean it feels
like maybe people are just so bored
they're so comfortable they're so cushy
they have everything that they want
these you know cuz these people that are
protesting and tea for these guys
they're not where they're college
educated white kids from the suburbs who
are upset it used to be when you were a
kid you used to just be like a goth or
something yeah right now you think the
world is ending because the plants on
fire and now you have to be a militant
and Tifa member and go smash things up
but that's bad and the day we just used
to go to raves and like do drugs and
like dance all night listen to crazy
music that was our that was our act of
rebellion back then so let's let's
combine all these things together and
I'll tell you what worries me active
members of the US government that are
publicly announcing their opposition to
the administration by any means
necessary talking about stopping the
president Trump just fired 70 of them
and I already see the comments from
people on Twitter this is the end he's
now a tyrant he's unstoppable
yeah come
buying that with a media that wants that
narrative because it gets clicks so they
rile everybody up and say what would you
do you they're saying you know I'm
saying people say now if you ever
wondered what you would have done if you
were in World War two Germany you're
doing it right now
that's right and then you get angry
scared kids many of whom have anxiety
disorders who had snowplow parents who
cleared away all the obstacles so they
never faced a challenge and they're
frail and terrified in words scare them
and you've got a powder keg yeah yeah
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you